Where I come from
it seems like everybody has an immigrant story.
The harbor in Buenos Aires
beckoned newcomers from over the world.
My ancestors were Italian, Spanish and Indian.
And the only thing I had to do was go out
of the house
to experience a different language a different
culture.
I remember sneaking out in spring
to celebrate Passover with my Jewish friends
we also had Lebanese neighbors
and their religious festivities
also became part of our celebrations in the
family.
I think that all Argentines carry a piece
of the world with them
and that’s why it’s relatively easy for
me
to walk in other people’s shoes.
My work is not only about political and social
issues.
I want to find out, what’s below the surface
the issues and the stories that have shaped
the people.
I want to show
that even though we are all different,
there is a general human condition
that connects us all.